montera classe important c'est super
intéressant six mois de france à ce
qu'il faut ça c'est l'italie vous avez
de la lumière sur votre cas c'est
vraiment de la sécurité pour les motards
y invitait de se planter en vous voyez
la signalisation ça va s'allumer par
rapport au fait vous allez mettre un
clignotant à droite à gauche vous avez
un petit boîtier connecté via les
brochettes directement à votre égal et
vous avez plein d'options vous avez de
la commande vocale notamment alex a
poussé la voir le train qui les rend
votre parcours du dal bref c'est
vachement bien cécile et alice est une
innovation française pour l'instant
c'est trop tôt pour les potes partira
bientôt sans marcher parce que sans ça
vraiment cool il vaut faire un petit
starter à l'indigo bientôt donc si vous
devez faire plaisir à papa